-This is such a wonderful film
You play someone
who's about to go to Yale
and feels like they maybe missed
out on high school.
Set it up for us a little bit.
-Yeah, so "Booksmart"
is about two characters.
Molly, who I play, and Amy
who the incredible Kaitlyn Dever
plays,
and they're inseparable
best friends
who have basically decided
high school is about each othe
and academics.
And on the last day of school,
my character learns that
the kids that she thought
were just being like frivolous
and going out
actually got into very goo
schools, as well,
and maybe that they
should have some fun.
And so they go on this
incredible adventurous night out
to prove that they are
smart and fun.
-Were you -- were you someon
who book smart
and being smart was
important to you?
-Yes. So from a very young age
I was, like, obsessed
with being smart.
And when I was 3 --
I'm the youngest.
so, I really wanted to,
like, do everything
that everyone else could do.
So, I wanted to prove
that I could read and writ
at, like, an advanced level.
And mind you, I was 3. Like,
I couldn't really do anything.
[ Laughter ]
Could maybe point to a "B," or
an "A."
But I begged my brother
to write down --
-Your brother Jonah Hill. Yes.
-My brother Jonah Hill --
I begged him --
[ Scattered cheers ]
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
I begged him to write down
"Willy Wonka
& the Chocolate Factory"
on a piece of paper for me
'cause that sounded very astut
to me.
I was like,
"That is a big word.
-Yes.
-And a lot of them in a row.
-Yeah.
-So, I begged him,
and he was like 13 at the time
So he was like, "Ugh fine.
So he writes it down, and I go
into my mom and dad's room
and I'm like,
"Mom, look what I wrote."
And she was like, "Jonah!"
And I was like,
"No, I wrote it. I wrote it.
She was like,
"You did not write this!"
And I run up to Jonah.
I'm like, "What did you write?
He was like,
"I wrote 'Eff you.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
So my attempt at being
book smart --
-Yeah, did not --
-My first attempt at being
book smart did not work out.
-It is a nice -- this film
is a nice companion film
to "Superbad."
-Yeah, it's --
-I mean, it is these
kind of like, two characters
who really love each other
-Yes.
-In a way that I feel like
you know --
I felt like I hadn't seen it
before that,
and I certainly haven't seen i
from this perspective.
-Yeah.
-And it must just be so nice
to do something, you know,
very, very different,
but also has that same
quality of heart.
-Yeah, I think if "Booksmart
owes to "Superbad,"
I think we owe this like
true celebration of friendship
as you said.
-Yeah.
-Like, these girls are
in love with each other.
And I think "Booksmart,"
it's so 2019.
It's rooted in now.
It feels so fresh,
and it's female.
-Yeah.
-And it's just like,
these girls are so smart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And they're unapologetic about
how smart they are,
and it's not
an assimilation story.
It's a story of girls
just owning their intellec
and their love for each other,
and their confidence.
It's great.
-It's nice how few of the --
There's none of those
cliché moves
that you become accustomed to...
-Yes.
-...in those high school movies.
I heard that, you know,
obviously,
you're playing friends,
and you did not know Kaitlyn
before this, I'm assuming.
-Yeah. No.
-But you guys lived together
during the shoot.
You kind of went all in on
the idea of being old friends?
-Exactly. We went all in.
Basically, we knew --
Molly and Amy had been
inseparable for over ten years
So we were like, "We have to
make up for lost time.
We just met."
And so we thought,
"There's no better way
to do that than
living together."
Olivia brought it up the first
time we met like, very casually.
She's like, "Maybe you could
live together."
And Kaitlyn and I were like,
"I'm down if you're down."
And this was like before
the appetizers had even arrived.
It was like ten minutes
into knowing each other.
We were like fully roomies
but it was incredible.
We just like ate like snacks
and like got ready
and brushed our teeth together
and ran lines, and it was --
it was honestly heaven.
I can't imagine doing
the movie without that.
-And you mentioned Olivia Wilde.
This was her first directing
gig.
-Yeah.
-And she just does
an amazing job.
And do you remember the firs
time you met her?
-Yeah. So I met her once
briefly before this.
But the first time we like sat
down together was at this café
in Times Square because she wa
doing "1984,"
and I was doing "Hello, Dolly!
at that time,
and I was just so
deeply inspired
by just sitting next to her.
But we had very different
approaches
to our, like, preshow ritual
So, I was doing "Hello, Dolly!
and she was doing "1984,"
and it was like right before
our shows, like an hour.
And I was sitting there like a
grandma with my little
like, hot water and honey,
and she had like six shots
of espresso.
[ Laughter ]
It was like one after the other.
Just like, pitching me the movie
in the best way,
and I was just enthralled.
She's radiant, she's brilliant
and she led our film with
such humanity and confidence
and it was just --
It was wonderful.
-You mentioned "Hello, Dolly!"
and I'm so -- I'm so delighted
that I got to see you onstag
in that show.
-Yes.
-And I know we sort of might
have established that Jona
was not the best older brother
But...
-He is.
-He is. And I know how muc
you guys --
-It's been like 20 years
since that story.
-Yeah, exactly. Well, he mor
than made up for it
because he got
a "Hello, Beanie!" tattoo
to honor your Broadway debut
[ Audience awws ]
-It's insane.
He said it very like, offhand.
He was like, "Maybe I'll get
a 'Hello, Beanie!' tattoo.
I was like, "Ha-ha."
[ Laughter ]
And then, he was like,
"Where should I get it?"
I was like, "Maybe like here."
Expecting it to be this big.
It's like that.
I mean, you can see.
-Yeah, I know.
-And they had to shave his arm
which is my favorite part.
[ Laughter ]
-I also -- I love talking
about your mom, Sharon.
-Yes, the queen.
-Last time you were here,
it was about how your vet --
your veterinarian fired he
because --
-She got fully fired.
-Yeah, she was difficult
to deal with.
[ Laughter ]
I want to show
your beautiful mom.
There she is.
-Look at her.
-She's gorgeous.
-She's so gorgeous.
-What's new with Sharon?
How's she doing?
-We found a new vet.
-Okay, you found a new vet
-We found a more accepting vet
of her --
What do you call it? Her -
-Peccadillos?
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
You know, she found a new vet,
but she's incredible.
She has this incredible charit
called Your Mom Cares.
-Great.
-That she is just working
so hard on.
They're bringing awareness
to children's
mental health issues.
I'm so proud of her.
She's the most incredible
inspiration to me.
-And then there's some great
guest stars, I should say,
you know, co-stars in the film
Will Forte, Jason Sudeikis..
-Some people you know.
-...Mike O'Brien,
some people I know.
And Lisa Kudrow.
And is it true that Lisa Kudro
was, of all the people,
she could recognize
from your family.
She saw your mom,
and was into that.
-Yeah, so we're at the premier
last week.
And she walks by me.
She walks by Jonah,
and she turns around to my mom
She goes, "Oh, my God.
You're on a commercial!"
And my mom -- I never have
seen her -- she's never rattled.
But my mom is in fact, on
a Facebook Portal commercial
[ Laughter ]
And Lisa knew, baby. Lisa knew
-Good for you, Sharon.
-You go, Shay.
-You go. Hey,
thanks for being here.
-So good to see you again.
-Congrats on the film.
-That's Beanie Feldstein,
everybody.